it's a very good question but what we
have seen in the last 18 months
especially with the local map croydon's
local met they've now reached out to the
community at large they've had young
people that are not necessarily from the
affluent communities young people from
local communities communities around
here like thornton heath south norwood
who are now training the met on local
policing how to work uh collaboratively
um to engage young people historically
we've had many uh breakdowns due to stop
and search but we now have young people
from croydon working with the met
training the met being paid to train the
met in how to police locally without
increasing further tensions
thank you reverend
first and the name of the church that
you come from okay my name is pastor
berelson james i'm a community pastor
street pastor i work in thornton heath
west croydon central croydon and pretty
much anywhere that there's footwork to
be done in your work do you often speak
to parents who are worried about their
children absolutely it's a main part of
the community program in speaking with
the parents
in for example
getting parents to find out who their
children's friends are who are they
meeting are they attending school
what is your if your child comes in
wearing a pair of
balenciagas
where did your child get them
get more involved speak with your child
find out what's going on in their lives
i know we all have to work we all have
duties to fulfill
but you cannot as a parent think that
it's okay to leave
the state to continually look after your
child we've got to get more involved and
do you think the onus really is that on
parents rather than schools and other
services i think it's something that has
to happen together
it's something that needs to work
together we're looking at the amount of
children that have been excluded from
schools
when you exclude a child
where are you putting them are you now
moving them out of the classroom into a
park
there is not enough follow-up work that
sits around
exclusion work
there are children that there are flags
and signposts that you can see that
there is trouble going on here
and i appreciate the finances and
everybody's got things to do but there
are some red flags that come up and part
of the work that we do for example
if it's school time
and you drive past a park and there are
15 children
that you can roughly work at their age
between 13 and 15.
there's no teacher there what are they
doing in the park you have to ask the
questions
part of the work that we do within the
church and i was just explaining on
boxing day got a call from her mother
please come to my house
got to the house she's pulled out one of
the biggest knives ever
as the church we're here to help to
collect some of these weapons we're here
to support you it's not just about
hallelujah we're on the floor
we're here to help signpost you give you
instructions help in getting your
children and keeping them safe
i guess if a parent sees something
suspicious or finds a knife in their
child's backpack i suppose they might
not first think of going to the police
because that could bring their child
into trouble i mean what would you say
what advice would you give in that sense
so you find the knife or you see
something that isn't quite right
if you don't want to speak with the
police and traditionally we've had some
issues around that but i will tell you
things are getting better but there are
organizations and people like myself
give us a call
across croydon we have many different
organizations there are intervening
grassroots systems that are available
get in touch with somebody it might be
that you making that call
saves the life of your child and
somebody else's
and finally when something tragic like
this happens in the community what is
the sort of questions or reflections
that people have
i think people often fail to recognize
the ripple effect of this
because it may look as if it is one
child
but the effects that happen
with that one child it's not just that
family that family will grieve there's
devastation there's heartache there's
pain but for all the other families that
are connected so that child may be your
nephew might be your cousin might be
your friend
it goes on and on and on
and then with people
like myself who are doing the counseling
we're counseling the family working with
the family we're working with the police
but there are other families who will
sit
and grieve also and we don't always see
that so it isn't just the death of one
it affects
so many people
morning everyone my name is alex murray
i'm a commander in the met police
responsible for getting violence down in
london
thanks very much for coming today
first and foremost i can't imagine the
pain that the families of
loved ones
two who have died
last night are feeling right now
it must be incredibly raw and i know
the thoughts of all the people i work
with in the met are with the moms dads
and families and brothers and sisters
of the young people who died last night
i do want to reassure you and say that
violence and tackling violence and youth
violence is our number one priority
in london
right from dealing with county lines
through to taking money and drugs and
guns off the streets
through to being in the right place at
the right time policing hot spots of
violence
and then getting upstream we've got
hundreds of police officers who work in
schools
all trying really hard to
tackle violence at its causes
now
as a result of that effort and with
partners and with community groups and
with the local authority we have seen
over the last few years significant
reductions in violence in knife crime
and gun crime
but not for teenagers for teenagers we
have had an increase in homicides
and i guess my message today other than
to speaking to the families and friends
of
those that london has lost tonight is to
say
you cannot carry knives in london this
is what happens when
uh
knives are carried
and we all have a role uh in relation to
tackling knife crime
uh anybody can ring crime stoppers an
independent charity
uh and call and say this person's got a
knife
or someone's carrying a knife an action
will be taken
we take about 400 knives a month off the
streets
from young people who are carrying
knives but in actual fact everybody has
a role to play here and is playing
and i just encourage anybody
who knows if someone is carrying a knife
tell them not to
we know people get hurt if you carry
knives
it's not something you should carry if
you're fearful if you're fearful don't
carry a knife that's the main comment
um and
i'd encourage everybody to get involved
you've seen how we work with community
groups to tackle violence this is a
local problem a family problem a
community problem a police problem a
local authority problem we've all got a
role to play
to make sure that we reduce
these tragedies that are taking place
[Music]
we have no intelligence and it's so
early at the moment not really free to
talk about the detail of the
two investigations
teenage homicides in london appreciate
what you just said about everyone having
to work together but clearly met isn't
need to do something different because
you're repeating that same message but
murders just keep on rising
yeah so the tragedy is teenage murders
are up total murder rate and knife crime
is down and we are doing a lot of
different things we're investing in
prevention putting officers in schools
as i mentioned we do a thing called
problem solving where we work in a
particular area where violence might
spike and we go what are the causes here
and we work with partners to deal
with those causes of crime and and
things like county lines which does
affect teenagers so much more we've
charged thousands of people with county
lines both here in london and people
exporting drugs
to some of the towns around the uk so a
huge amount of effort is going on with
thousands and thousands of
police officers both in the prevention
space and also in detecting crime and
getting justice for victims the the
detection rate for homicide in london is
nearly 95 you know it's very high and
there's a lot of i've just been speaking
to detectives involved in the case
um a huge amount of effort has gone in
getting justice for victims and actually
solving the homicides when they happen
but the youngest who are the victims of
this are still
disproportionately represented surely
there needs to be a different strategy
at this point we you're right about the
disproportionality and it's the
disproportionality we don't hear about
so much so you you know young lads in
london and it's young black lads in
london largely uh who are affected
more than anyone else and we need to
really start understanding uh that and
dealing with it
and from a policing point of view it's
represented in our data you know
when we look at people who are both
victims and who are charged with
homicide we see
disproportionality and it's something
we've got to work really hard on dealing
with and again that's that's not just
the police that's all of us working
together
in the public sector but also in the
private sector and also families ngos
community groups churches
so there's clearly a lot of distrust
still i get you know for the police and
some of the communities so how do you
tackle that
we tackle that by building relationships
now you've spoken to anthony earlier
through the good times and through the
bad times the police will never leave
and the community groups will never
leave we've got to work together the
bigger picture is stopping
young people getting hurt that you've
just described that's what the police
care about that's what the community
groups care about and when we realize
that our motivation both our motivations
are really good in tackling that that's
when we start to build trust and you've
seen here in croydon excuse me over the
last 18 months you know bridges being
built between community groups and the
police because we realize that our
motivation is to make a change and to to
tackle what you've described around
teenage homicides and do you think that
you've got enough people
from local communities really
represented in the meds so they're able
to build those bridges and so that
people that they approach can have the
confidence that their
pleas will be taken seriously
so along with getting violence now
being representative and building trust
with communities is our one and two
objectives in london
a huge amount of effort is making us
representative on recruiting more people
from the communities that we serve and
we're making great strides in that area
and it's really really encouraging
so i've just been speaking to the local
superintendent we have a lot of extra
offices on because it's new year's eve
we will be policing from now over the
weekend in the parks in the spaces where
violence tends to peak
we'll be dealing with some of the
parties where again
again violence tends to peak
and there is a significant uplift in
resources both
in the geography in areas that we're
concerned about but also
tackling some of the gangs tackling some
of the importation of drugs some of the
money launders the whole scale of it is
aimed at bringing down violence and
that's happening right now
[Music]
knife crime prevention orders these are
orders that on conviction
uh they are they can be given to an
individual or if there's a lot of
intelligence that they carry knives and
they're right at their early days at the
moment so we've got many of applications
through the court and it's impossible to
say whether they are effective or not
but with we're testing that and that's
just another one of the many things that
we're doing
knife crime prevention orders
we're dealing with people who market
knives people who sell knives
we're taking huge amounts off the street
so
virtually from every angle you can
imagine we're tackling the violent crime
associated with both guns and knives
tonight
well what i'd say to everyone is there's
a huge police presence out tonight but
if you if you have concerns um
talk to your kids uh make sure they're
not carrying knives make sure they're
not hanging around with kids carrying
knives um and if you do have a concern
that they've got a knife under their bed
or their friends got a knife under the
bed that's what crime stoppers is for
it's independent you're anonymous you
can make the call and we can make a
change and that's that's the point we we
don't know who has knives but we can
find out and we can stop them
hurting someone or being hurt and you
know don't listen to it from me
there's an incredible campaign that i'd
encourage all of your viewers to watch
it's called hardcall saves lives and
it's from five or six moms here in
london who've lost their sons to knives
and it's them saying
please look call crime stoppers if
someone's carrying a knife it's a hard
call but it can save a life from the
child that might get killed but also
from the child that might end up being
incarcerated for years and years
i think there's a there's a number
of factors now it's worth saying that
even for
knife injury under 25s
it's significantly down it's 30 or 40
down but for teenagers in particular
there's probably
three things operating one is
the glorification of knives on social
media and
credibility and people cussing each
other on social media we're seeing it
again and again and again and we're
taking videos off youtube all the time
but it is incredibly provocative
at the same time we've got
changing drug markets and the emergence
of county lines in the last few years
that we're really focusing on
and the other one is just
the amount of people carrying knives the
amount of young people carrying knives
it's got to be unacceptable and it's got
to be unacceptable for them and it's no
good me saying that but it is really
important that everyone else
also says it
and that's why we're out there and
that's why we are taking knives off the
street but it's probably those
three things intersecting
to cause the the peak in teenage
homicides
was it a number of things can happen if
they if they speak to crime stoppers if
they don't want to speak to the police
um then the intervention can go through
crime stoppers but i would ask them to
reach out to people in the community who
they know and trust or to speak to the
police because i can say the police can
be trusted and say look i'm concerned
here what can you do
we could
make referrals you know there's youth
groups out there there are ngos there's
uh people like anthony king who
represent a number of different groups
who could intervene with that individual
i mean
the main message to a parent who's
concerned about a child is if their
child is carrying a knife that's when
they that's when they're going to get
hurt
and so
what do whatever you can to intervene to
stop those knives being carried
next year to make sure next year
the
ambition of the commissioner and the
metropolitan police is unwavering around
violence it will remain the number one
focus
with building trust with communities
so next year we will be focusing our
efforts in area where knife prime is the
highest we'll be problem solving we'll
be pushing into schools
we'll still be taking knives off the
streets but we'll be dealing with those
drivers of violence as well drugs guns
and money
and we have operation arachi which is
tackling county lines we're upscaling
that considerably so that's getting
bigger and bigger and bigger if you if
you're engaged in county lines the
chances are you're you're you're going
to get caught
and there is
an absolute laser-like focus on county
lines and violence here in london next
year
[Music]
so the
violence in london
if you heard the mayor's speak just
before speech just before christmas as
well it's not up it's down considerably
so robberies are down about 40
knife stabbing for under 25s is down
about 40
total murders is down
as i mentioned that
the bad bit
is the tragedy of these young men being
killed here on the streets of london uh
and teenagers and
why that is getting worse is that
i mentioned the changing drug market
some of the social media
um
videos uh often drill videos that are
encouraging it localized
um
videos where people are given to come on
to another group
and
and kids carrying knives
and that becoming more acceptable in
those circles and that's what we have to
stop
[Music]
anything you want to send to the family
well to the to the family of this 15
year old lad
and to the family of the young man
who was killed in hillingdon
you know the poignancy of the time of
year
teenagers myself
all i can say is that
the met is reaching out to you we'll do
everything we can to bring those
offenders to justice we can't imagine
the pain
that you are going through
but you must know
that we are absolutely committed to a
bringing those offenders to justice but
also to tackling violence
across the whole of london so that more
mums and dads and brothers and sisters
don't have to be in a position that
they're in right now and i can't imagine
the unbearable pain that they must be in
right now
thank you very much everyone